when i talk about these criminal
organizations
each uh trafficking organization
cartel owns a certain segment they've
got
cartel bosses that own plazas they're
plaza bosses so you know it could be
five miles or ten miles of an area and
so when you come up to the border you're
paying a tax in order to cross in that
area on that side on yeah from from the
mexican side of the u.s side so i mean
and when i talk about billion dollar
industry so mexican national he or she
is going to pay between the cheapest
would be about 2500 all the way up to
about five grand
um
central american five to ten grand an
indian national the tax they're paying
on the mexican side well this is to get
smuggled right oh then when you get
muggled so you get to the border this is
part of your smuggling feed you're
paying a total fee of let's say it's 10
10 grand right okay but then when i show
up at the border this plaza boss says
i know you paid roy to come across but
you haven't paid my tax yet so now you
owe me 500 or 300 800 to cross here so
you have to keep that money on you on
your person while you're going that
distance it's a little bit of both
you'll see folks that travel with money
in their in their hands and their
pockets hidden away and then there's a
lot of money that gets wired um you know
it's it's a huge industry uh money being
wired into mexico so like
uh i think it's the number three or
number five but part of mexico's gdp
their gross domestic domestic product
one of the the largest uh gdp earners is
remittances from the us into mexico wow
and it's the same thing in central
america where you've got folks that are
sending money back so they'll wire a
smuggler here you know here's the 300
bucks that i can cross in your plaza
wow it's it's just it's big bucks but
like an indian national it's going to
40 thousand dollars chinese
about 50 grand um someone who's uh from
a um
a uh
a country that that may be on like maybe
perceived as being a terrorist country
not that they're terrorists but could be
received as such
easily 80 grand and that's what they're
going to chart that the
the smug organization or the coyote is
going to charge he's going to charge and
and the the
the organization in and of itself is
very disciplined in that you've got
folks that they do the recruitment um
they're all over social media so you can
go onto facebook and and
find uh sites that'll
offer smuggling and then so you got the
recruiters you've got the handlers on
the mexican side that that they house
you and feed you until you're being
ready to be crossed you've got the folks
that will just get you across the border
and then you've got those that'll cross
you once across the border into the u.s
and then you've got logistics teams that
do the transport so just all different
so depending on how much money you have
is the type of treatment you can get
along the way kind of
kind of sort i mean you're going to pay
a lump sum but each segment someone's
getting paid right
the thing is
with each segment as you're getting paid
along well you're not in other words i'm
paying you you're the organizer right
you're the responder i give you my 40
grand and then that smuggler as as the
person's being moved along
pays roy a portion okay i see somebody
else abortion so he's breaking everybody
off you kind of have the guy that's the
bank yeah yeah exactly
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one